alors hier on a écouté la version des
trois jeunes filles qui s'exprime et
extrêmement bien qui nous ont raconté
l'histoire aujourd'hui on aimerait avoir
votre version et c'est tout à fait
normal d'avoir votre version aujourd'hui
raphaël
oui donc vous vous est pris pour cible
dans cette affaire
qu'est ce que vous dites sur le
harcèlement dont on a parlé dans cette
émission
et s'il reste que pour vous c'est cc
c'est ce que vous dites c'est des
inepties ou est-ce que vous ressentez
non alors cessé d inepties après du
harcèlement c'est un mot qui est très
fort évidemment il ya des querelles
entre candidats on le voit à l'antenne
voilà il ya beaucoup de turenne
maintenant dire que c'est du harcèlement
je suis je ne pense pas non
d'accord c'est quoi c'est pour vous
c'est quoi ces les bruins et des cd dac
taquineries mai mais aujourd'hui c'est
ce que vous pouvez retrouver partout
dans la rue sur une situation
d'automobilistes osé dans les écoles il
ya des querelles tout le monde ne
s'entend pas forcément on s'embrouille
oui évidemment réaliser la violence
aussi parce que mais on nous a dit qu'on
a une qui a failli prendre un oui un
coup de poing dans la gueule et on a eu
une voix là qui a pris voilà c'était
court oui on vous a reproché d'avoir
étranglé une jeune fille et vous
l'auriez reconnu dans une terre alors je
vous explique ça à l'époque c'était ma
compagne j'avais 18 ans je n'ai pas être
anglais et effectivement c'est vrai je
l'approuvé par le coup d'accord c'est
alors c'est pas quelque chose à faire je
vous dis pas mal an j'avais 18 ans mais
cela traduit par le coup parce qu'elle
m'a traitée de d'un nom d'oiseau
d'accord ce devant et des raisons 50
personnes ans et pas une ride c'est sûr
et certain
mais j'avais 18 ans que ça m'est arrivé
qu'une seule fois maintenant je mets au
défi n'importe qui d'autre d'accord de
trouver quelque chose
alors oui j'ai eu un tort j'ai eu 18 ans
je dis pas que c'est mais c'est
pardonnable jusque voilà j'étais un peu
plus jeune est un peu plus bête j'ai été
beaucoup plus raphaël oui dans l'
enquête que j'ai fait et en recueillant
des témoignages il est quand même avéré
que vous êtes protégé surprotégé par la
production et que la production selon
des témoignages que j'ai vous inciterait
même à faire acte d'harcèlement de
provocation pour que les alors être les
plombs alors donc j'ai fait une question
que je vous pose d'accord est ce que
c'est je vais et je pense mais je vais
vous répondre tout cela a laissé le
répondre aux journalistes
oui oui d'accord alors fait très bien
votre travail s'il vous plaît parce que
en aucun cas d'accord en aucun cas
je dis bien ici la production me demande
d'harceler des gens d'accord et en aucun
cas moi d'accord j'accepterai si on me
demandait d'harceler des gens donc c'est
très important de bien faire son boulot
parce que c'est votre métier aujourd'hui
de relater les faits et de dire si oui
ou non c'est vrai faites très bien votre
avis parce que c'est un sujet très
sensible aujourd'hui le harcèlement
d'accord et moi en aucun cas je me
serais permis d'harceler une femme alors
oui nicolas alors attendez qu est-ce que
vous est ce qu'on met le harcèlement
parce que voilà moi j'ai été admis à
présenter une enquête
hélas est ce que je peux vous dire c'est
quand je vois un homme qui lie à une
femme en jupe d'aller mettre un short et
l'a menacée c'est du harcèlement
d'accord mais vous vous parlez quoi je
parle de votre comportement en général
il ya quand même des images qui passent
sur votre comportement
le harcèlement c'est du harcèlement donc
de temps en temps quelqu'un de l'arsel
m'attendais de quelle image vous parle
je parle de temps en règle générale dans
l'est dans les temps du match vous avez
vu dans les angles exactement ma raison
jouer mais les tiennent non plus je n'ai
pas non plus vous dire si c'est le 5 6 7
ou 8 mai mais vous savez très bien de
quoi je parle un moment donné il ya une
vidéo
oui une jeune fille qui est en quête
enquête en juin et voulait traiter
quasiment de pub parce qu'elle est en
jupe et vous alors le big bang des
bêtisiers vous explosez des bêtises on
l'a fait s'est dérouté pas là merci
parce que c'est ma copine à l'époque
alors attendez mais si j'ai pas envie
qu'elle se mette en jeu
à cette époque le temps d'accord et vous
allez on attendait qu'ils vous regardent
vous avez des valeurs mes muscles à
chacun ses valeurs et à chacun ses
principes d'acord à côté de ça on est
d'accord vous c'était votre copine à moi
à l'époque c'est ma copine elle va voir
un producteur d'accord faut remettre
dans le contexte va voir un producteur
de chant je suis noir s'il te plaît ne
met pas cette jupe
moi je préfère que tu mettes important
pour y aller est-ce que c'est du
harcèlement est considéré ça comme tu
dis non c'est très intéressant ce que tu
dis nicolas ces images ont été diffusées
on voit la dette ici en 2015
qu'est ce qui est passé par là depuis
mis tout à l'époque les anges c'est un
carton ça faisait huit cent mille
téléspectateurs choqués parce que ça ça
n'est pas vu par du harcèlement comme du
harcèlement
c'est perçu comme une jalousie comme il
peut y en avoir dans plein de couple